des échanges et des dédicaces dans les
mêmes conditions que les grands noms de
la littérature contemporaine
lisez locale en est à sa neuvième
édition et comme d'habitude ce sont des
auteurs yvelinois qui sont derrière la
table l'idée en fait ça chaque fois
c'est de faire venir des auteurs locaux
ou en tout cas de petites maisons
d'édition qui n'ont pas une grande
communication comme les auteurs de
littérature et voilà de les promouvoir
et de faire en sorte qu'ils soient un
petit peu connu du grand public d'un
roman d'actualité sur une mer qui
s'imaginent montrer sa vie en immersion
au président de la république emmanuel
macron à une analyse des rapports entre
l'infrastructure de l'internet et la
politique
cette session orienté sciences humaines
accueilli au total cinq auteurs de 15
heures à 19 heures j'hésite toujours que
je ne vis pas de l'écriture mais que
l'écriture me fait vivre voilà au sens
large du terme
évidemment je fais pas partie de ces
auteurs qui ont la chance de ne pouvoir
faire que ça mais je ne fais quand même
que ce afin que ça j'ai un métier à côté
charles dans l'immobilier mais c'est ma
vie c'est le centre voilà mais le
battement de mon coeur sont là une
manière de varier d activité de la
librairie qui a eu 30 ans le 1er avril
et qui entend bien résisté face au géant
d'internet c'est sympa ça change
l'activité strictement commercial ça
permet d'avoir d'autre chose de
rencontrer des gens mais deux voisins je
ne connaissez pas leurs livres
ça m'a donné envie de les lire prochaine
rencontre lisez locale le samedi 15 juin
consacré cette fois ci à la littérature